This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On April 9th, 2017, United Airlines Flight 3411 was about to fly from Chicago to Louisville, when flight attendants discovered the plane was over-bucked. They tried to get volunteers to give up their seats with promises of travel vouchers and hotel accommodations, but not enough people were willing to get off. United ended up calling some Airpoint security officers. They boarded the plane, and forcibly removed a passenger named Dr. David Dow. The officers ripped Dow out of his seat
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2017年4月9日，联合航空3411号航班正准备从芝加哥飞往路易斯维尔，当时乘务员发现飞机超售了。他们试图通过提供旅行代金券和酒店住宿来招募自愿放弃座位的乘客，但没有足够的人愿意下机。美联航最终叫来了几名机场保安。他们登上了飞机，并强行带走了一名叫大卫·道（David Dao）的博士。保安把道博士从座位上硬生生地拽了下来，
and carried him down the aisle of the airplane, nose bleeding, while horrified on-mogor shot video with their phones. while horrified on-mokers shot video with their phones. Oh, this is so much fun. Oh my God, look at what you're taking there. You probably remember this incident and the outrage it generated. The international uproar continued over the forced removal of a passenger from a United Airlines flight.
把他拖过飞机的过道，他的鼻子在流血，而惊恐的同机乘客则用手机拍下了视频。哦，这太好玩了。天哪，看看你在拍什么。你可能还记得这起事件以及它所引发的愤怒。这起因将乘客从联合航空航班上强行带走而引发的国际众怒仍在持续。
Today the airline CEO Oscar Munoz issued an apology saying, quote, no one should ever be mistreated this way. I want you to know that we take full responsibility. But why Dr. Tao? How did he end up being the unlucky passenger that United decided to remove? Immediately following the incident, some people thought racial discrimination may have played a part, and it's possible that this played a role in how he was treated. But the answer to how he was chosen was actually, an algorithm, a computer program. It crunched through a bunch of data, looking at stuff like how
今天，该航空公司首席执行官奥斯卡·穆诺斯（Oscar Munoz）发表道歉声明，称：“任何人都不应以这种方式受到虐待。我想让你们知道，我们承担全部责任。”但为什么是陶博士？他是如何成为美联航决定带走的那个不幸乘客的？事件发生后不久，一些人认为种族歧视可能起到了作用，这种因素确实有可能影响了对他的对待方式。但关于他是如何被选中的，答案其实是一个算法，一个计算机程序。它处理了一堆数据，查看诸如
much each passenger had paid for their ticket, what time they checked in, how often they flew ununited, and whether they were part of a rewards program. The algorithm likely determined that Dr. Dow was one of the least valuable customers on the flight at the time. Algorithms shape our world in profound and mostly invisible ways. They predict if we'll be valuable customers or whether we're likely to repay alone. They filter what we see on social media, sort through resumes, and evaluate job performance. They inform prison sentences and monitor our health. Most of these algorithms have been created with good intentions.
每个乘客为机票支付了多少钱、他们是什么时候办理登机手续的、他们坐美联航航班的频率如何，以及他们是否加入了奖励计划等内容。算法很可能判定，道博士是当时航班上价值最低的乘客之一。算法以深远且大多隐蔽的方式塑造着我们的世界。它们预测我们会成为有价值的客户还是会偿还贷款。它们过滤我们在社交媒体上看到的内容、筛选简历并评估工作表现。它们为量刑提供参考并监测我们的健康状况。其中绝大多数算法在创建时都怀揣着良好的意图。
The goal is to replace subjective judgments with objective measurements, but it doesn't always work out like that. This subject is huge. I think algorithm design may be the big design problem of the 21st century, and that's why I wanted to interview Cathy O'Neill. Okay, well, thank you so much. So, because when we start, can you give me one of them, sort of, MPR style introductions and just say your name and what you do?
其目标是用客观测量来取代主观判断，但事情并不总是如愿以偿。这个主题太庞大了。我认为算法设计可能是21世纪最大的设计问题，这就是为什么我想采访凯西·奥尼尔（Cathy O'Neil）。好的，非常感谢。那么，在我们开始时，你能给我一个类似美国国家公共广播电台（NPR）风格的介绍，说出你的名字和你是做什么的吗？
Sure. I'm Cathy O'Neill. I'm a math magician, data scientist, activist, and author. I wrote the book, Weapons of Math Destruction, How Big Data Increases Inequality and Threatens Democracy. O'Neill studied number theory and then left academia to build predictive algorithms for a hedge fund. But she got really disillusioned by the use of mathematical models in the financial industry. I wanted to have more impact in the world, but I didn't really know that that impact could be really terrible. I was very naive.
当然。我是凯西·奥尼尔。我是一名数学魔术师、数据科学家、活动家和作家。我写了一本书，叫做《数学毁灭武器：大数据如何加剧不平等并威胁民主》（Weapons of Math Destruction, How Big Data Increases Inequality and Threatens Democracy）。奥尼尔曾研究数论，随后离开学术界，为一家对冲基金构建预测算法。但她对金融行业中数学模型的使用彻底幻灭了。“我想在世界上产生更大的影响，但我真的不知道这种影响会是如此糟糕。我当时太天真了。”
After that, O'Neill worked as a data scientist at a couple of startups. And through these experiences, she started to get worried about the influence of poorly designed algorithms. So we'll start with the most obvious question. What is an algorithm? At its most basic, an algorithm is a step-by-step guide to solving a problem.
在那之后，奥尼尔在几家初创公司担任数据科学家。通过这些经历，她开始对设计糟糕的算法的影响感到担忧。那么，我们从最明显的问题开始。什么是算法？最基础地说，算法是解决问题的逐步指南。
It's a set of instructions like a recipe. The example I like to give is like cooking dinner for my family. So in this case, the problem is how to make a successful dinner. O'Neill starts with a set of ingredients. And as she's creating the meal, she's constantly making choices about what ingredients are healthy enough to include in her dinner algorithm.
它是一套类似于食谱的指令。我喜欢给出的例子就像为我的家人做晚饭。所以在这种情况下，问题是如何做出一次成功的晚餐。奥尼尔从一组食材开始。在她制作餐食的过程中，她不断地做出选择，决定哪些食材健康到足以纳入她的晚餐算法中。
I curate that data because those ramen noodle packages that my kids like so much. I don't think of those as ingredients, right? So I exclude them, I'm curating, and therefore imposing my agenda on this algorithm. In addition to curating the ingredients, O'Neill as the cook also defines what a successful outcome looks like. I'm also defining success, right? I'm in charge of success. I define success to be if my kids eat vegetables at that meal. And you know, a different cook might define success differently. You know, my eight-year-old would define success to be like whether he got to eat Nutella. So that's another way where we the builders impose our agenda on the algorithm.
我策划这些数据是因为我孩子们非常喜欢的那些拉面包装。我不认为那些是食材，对吧？所以我把它们排除在外，我在策划，因此是将我的议程强加给这个算法。除了策划食材外，身为厨师的奥尼尔还定义了成功的结局是什么样的。我也在定义成功，对吧？我负责定义成功。我将成功定义为我的孩子们在那顿饭里吃了蔬菜。你知道，不同的厨师可能会对成功有不同的定义。你知道，我八岁的儿子可能会把成功定义为他是否能吃到能多益（Nutella）。所以这也是我们这些构建者将我们的议程强加给算法的另一种方式。
O'Neill's main point here is that algorithms aren't really objective, even when they're carried out by computers. This is relevant because the companies that build them like to market them as objective, claiming they remove human error and fallibility from complex decision-making. But every algorithm reflects the priorities and judgments of its human designer. Of course, that doesn't necessarily make algorithms bad. Right. So, I mean, it's very important to me that I don't get the reputation of hating all algorithms. I actually like algorithms, and I think algorithms could really help.
奥尼尔在这里的主要观点是，算法其实并不是客观的，即使它们是由计算机执行的。这一点之所以相关，是因为构建它们的公司的市场推广喜欢将其包装为客观的，声称它们消除了复杂决策中的人为错误和易错性。但每一个算法都反映了其人类设计者的优先级和判断。当然，这并不一定意味着算法是坏的。对。所以，对我很重要的一点是，我没有落得讨厌所有算法的名声。我其实喜欢算法，并且我认为算法真的能提供帮助。
But O'Neill does single out a particular kind of algorithm for scrutiny. These are the ones we should worry about. And they're characterized by three properties that they're very widespread and important, so like they make important decisions about a lot of people. Number two, that they're secret, that the people don't understand how they're being scored, and number three, that they're destructive. Like one bad mistake in the design, if you will, of these algorithms,
但奥尼尔确实挑出了一种特定类型的算法进行审视。这些正是我们应该担心的。它们的特点具有三个属性：它们非常普遍且重要，也就是说它们对很多人做出重要的决定；第二，它们是秘密的，人们并不理解自己是如何被评分的；第三，它们是破坏性的。就像这些算法设计中的一个严重错误，如果你愿意这么说的话，
will actually not only make it unfair for individuals, but categorically unfair for enormous populations as it gets scaled up. O'Neill has a shorthand for these algorithms. The widespread, mysterious, and destructive ones. She calls them Weapons of Math Destruction. To show how one of these destructive algorithms works, O'Neill points to the criminal justice system. For hundreds of years, key decisions in the legal process, like the amount of bail, length of sentence,
不仅会对个人不公平，而且随着规模扩大，会对庞大的人群造成绝对的不公平。奥尼尔对这些算法有一个简称。那些普遍存在、神秘莫测且具有破坏性的算法。她称之为“数学毁灭武器”。为了展示其中一种破坏性算法是如何运作的，奥尼尔指出了刑事司法系统。几百年来，法律程序中的关键决定，比如保释金金额、刑期长短，
and likelihood of parole, have been in the hands of fallible human beings guided by their instincts, and sometimes their personal biases. The judges are sort of famously racist, some of them more than others. And that racism can produce very different outcomes for defendants.
以及假释的可能性，一直掌握在容易犯错的人类手中，他们受直觉引导，有时也受个人偏见的驱使。法官们某种程度上以种族主义闻名，其中一些人比其他人更严重。而这种种族主义会给被告带来截然不同的结果。
For example, the ACLU has found that sentences imposed on black men in the federal system are nearly 20% longer than those for white men convicted of similar crimes. And studies have shown that prosecutors are more likely to seek the death penalty for African Americans than for whites convicted of the same charges. So you might think that computerized models fed by data would contribute to more even handed treatment. The criminal justice system thinks so too. It has increasingly tried to minimize human bias by turning to risk assessment algorithms.
例如，美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）发现，在联邦系统中对黑人男性的判刑比因类似罪行定罪的白人男性长近20%。研究表明，与因相同罪名被定罪的白人相比，检察官更有可能对非裔美国人寻求死刑。所以你可能会认为，由数据喂养的计算机模型会有助于更公正的处理。刑事司法系统也是这么认为的。它越来越多地通过转向风险评估算法来试图将人类偏见降到最低。
Like crime risk, like what is the chance of someone coming back to prison after leaving it? Many of these risk algorithms look at a person's record of arrests and convictions. The problem is, that data is already skewed by some social realities. Take for example the fact that white people and black people use marijuana at roughly equal rates. And yet, there's five times as many blacks getting arrested for smoking pot as whites. Five times as many. This may be because black neighborhoods tend to be more heavily police than white neighborhoods, which means black people get arrested for certain crimes
比如犯罪风险，比如某人在出狱后重新回到监狱的可能性是什么？许多此类风险算法会查看个人的逮捕和定罪记录。问题在于，这些数据已经被某些社会现实所扭曲。以白人和黑人大麻使用率大致相当这一事实为例。然而，因吸食大麻而被捕的黑人数量是白人的五倍。整整五倍。这可能是因为黑人社区往往比白人社区受到更严密的警力监控，这意味着黑人因某些犯罪而被捕的频率比白人更高。
more often than white people. Risk algorithms detect these patterns and apply them to the future. So if the past is shaped in part by racism, the future will be too. The larger point is we have terrible data here. But the statisticians involved, the data scientists, are like blindly going forward and pretending that our data is good, and then we're using it to actually make important decisions. Risk assessment algorithm is also look at defendants' answers to a questionnaire that's supposed to tease out certain risk factors.
风险算法检测到这些模式并将其应用到未来。因此，如果过去在一定程度上是由种族主义塑造的，未来也将如此。更广泛的观点是，我们这里的数据糟糕透顶。但参与其中的统计学家、数据科学家就像盲目前行一样，假装我们的数据很好，然后我们用它来实际做出重要的决定。风险评估算法还会查看被告对一份旨在探究某些风险因素的问卷的回答。
They have questions like, you know, did you grow up in high crime neighborhood? Are you on welfare? Do you have a mental health problem? Do you have addiction problems? Did your father go to prison? You know, they're basically proxies for race and class, but it's embedded in this scoring system, the judge is given the score and it's called objective. What is what is the judge take away from it or you know, how is it used? If you have a high risk score, it's used to send you to prison for longer in sentencing. There's also it's also used in bail hearings and parole hearings. If you have a high recidivism risk or you don't get parole. And presumably, you could take all that biased input data and say this high chance
他们有一些问题，你知道的，比如你是在高犯罪率社区长大的吗？你在领取福利吗？你有心理健康问题吗？你有瘾癖问题吗？你父亲进过监狱吗？你知道的，它们基本上是种族和阶级的替代指标，但它被嵌入到这个评分系统中，法官得到了这个分数，并且它被称为客观的。法官从中得到了什么，或者说它是如何被使用的？如果你有高风险评分，它在量刑时会被用来把你送进监狱更长时间。此外，它还被用于保释听证会和假释听证会。如果你有很高的累犯风险，你就无法获得假释。据推测，你可以拿走所有那些有偏见的输入数据，并说这个很高的累犯几率意味着我们应该进行更多的矫治。我的意思是，你可以拿走所有这些相同的东西，并选择对算法的结果做完全不同的事情。这正是我的观点。这完全是我的观点。我们可以说，哦，我很好奇为什么具有这种特征的人会有这么糟糕的累犯率。
for cynivism means that we should rehabilitate more. I mean, you could take that all the same stuff and choose to do a completely different thing with the result of the algorithm. That's exactly my point. Exactly my point. We could say, oh, I wonder why people who have this characteristic have so much worse serosidivism.
好吧，让我们试着帮他们找一份工作。也许这会有所帮助。我们可以使用这些算法、这些风险评分来试图说明我们的社会问题。相反，奥尼尔说，在许多情况下，我们实际上是在因为那些他们几乎无法控制的社会和结构性问题而惩罚人们，而且我们正在使用这些新的技术工具在大规模地这样做。
Well, let's try to help them find a job. Maybe that'll help. We could use those algorithms, those risk scores to try to account for our society. Instead, O'Neal says, in many cases, we're effectively penalizing people for societal and structural issues that they have little control over, and we're doing it at a massive scale, using these new technological tools.
如果你愿意的话，我们正在将责任从本应承担这些问题的社会转移到个人身上，并因此惩罚他们。必须指出的是，在某些情况下，算法正在帮助朝着更好的方向改变刑事司法系统的某些要素。例如，新泽西州最近废除了现金保释系统，该系统对低收入被告不利。取而代之的是，他们现在依靠预测算法。数据显示，该州审前县监狱的人口下降了约20%。
We're shifting the blame, if you will, from the society, which is the one that should own these problems to the individual and punishing them for it. It should be said that, in some cases, algorithms are helping to change elements of the criminal justice system for the better. For example, New Jersey recently did away with their cash bail system, which disadvantaged low-income defendants. They now rely on predictive algorithms instead. Data shows that the state's pre-trial county jail populations are downed by about 20%.
尽管如此，诸如此类的算法仍然没有接受审计和监管，当算法基本上成为黑箱时，这就成了一个问题。在许多情况下，它们是由将其实际出售给其他公司的私营企业设计的，其工作原理的准确细节仍然是个秘密。不仅公众蒙在鼓里，甚至连使用这些东西的公司也可能并不完全了解数据是如何被处理的。奥尼尔研究过的许多有问题的算法都是如此，无论是用于筛选贷款申请还是评估教师表现。
But still, algorithms like that one remain unaudited and unregulated, and it's a problem when algorithms are basically black boxes. In many cases, they're designed by private companies who sell them to other companies, and the exact details of how they work on CapSecret. Not only is the public in the dark, even the companies using these things, might not understand exactly how the data is being processed. This is true of many of the problematic algorithms that O'Neill has looked at, whether they use for sorting loan applications or assessing teacher performance.
当数学分数被拿出来时，人们身上会发生某种奇怪的事情。他们只是开始闭上眼睛去相信它，因为它是数学。而且他们确实会这样，我感觉就像是，哦，我不是数学专家，所以我无法反击。这就是你一次又一次看到的情况。你会想，你为什么不质疑这个？这根本说不通。
There's some kind of weird thing that happens to people when mathematical scores are trotted out. They just start closing their eyes and believing it because it's math. And they do, I feel like, oh, I'm not an expert of math, so I can't push back. And that's something you just see time and time again. You're like, why didn't you question this? This doesn't make sense.
哦，好吧，这是数学，我不懂。现在看起来，由于算法和数学的存在，它只是一个推卸责任的新地方，这样你作为一家真正的公司就不必去思考你的决策了。因为这些东西实在是太强大了，而且你知道的，对我们来说太迷人了，尤其是在现在，它们可以被用于各种各样的邪恶方式，它们几乎是神奇的，对吧？
Oh, well, it's math and I don't understand it. Right now it seems like because of algorithms and math, it's just a new place to place blame so that you do not have to think about your decisions as an actual company Because these things are just so powerful and so you know mesmerizing to us especially right now They can be used in all kinds of Nafaria's way they're almost magical is that Yeah
那是，嗯，挺吓人的。它是可怕的，而且我认为，我会比那更进一步。是的，那是，嗯，挺吓人的。它是可怕的，而且我认为我会，我会比那更进一步。我只是通过观察觉得，这些算法并不是随机出现的。当人们想要逃避一个非常困难的对话时，它们就会出现。
That's um scary It's scary and I think I think I go like I would go one step further than that Yeah, that's um, scary. It's scary and I think I would go, I would go one step further than that. I feel like just by observation that these algorithms, they don't show up randomly. They show up when there's a really difficult conversation that people want to avoid.
他们会觉得，哦，我们不知道什么才是好老师。不同的人对此有不同的看法。所以让我们通过让算法给老师打分来绕过这个对话。或者我们不知道监狱到底是用来干什么的。让我们有一种方法来决定判处某人多长时间监禁。我们引入这些银弹式的数学算法，是因为我们不想去讨论如何决定判处某人多长时间监禁。我们引入这些银弹式的数学算法，是因为我们不想进行对话。
They're like, oh, we don't know what it, what makes a good teacher. And different people have different opinions about that. So let's just bypass this conversation by having an algorithm score teachers. Or we don't know what prison is really for. Let's have a way of deciding how long to sentence somebody. We introduce these silver bullet mathematical algorithms because we don't want to have a way of deciding how long to sentence somebody. We introduce these silver bullet mathematical algorithms because we don't wanna have a conversation.
在奥尼尔的书里，她写了一个名叫凯尔·宾（Kyle Beam）的年轻人，他休学一段时间去治疗双相情感障碍。一旦他康复并准备好重返学校，他就去克罗格（Kroger）申请了一份兼职工作，克罗格是一家大型杂货店连锁企业。他有一个在那里工作的朋友主动提出为他担保。凯尔是一名如此优秀的学生，以至于他认为申请流程只是一种形式，
In O'Neill's book, she writes about this young guy named Kyle Beam, who takes some time off college to get treated for bipolar disorder. Once he's better and ready to go back to school, he applies for a part-time job at Crocker, which is a big grocery store chain. He has a friend who works there who offers to vouch for him. Kyle was such a good student that he figured the application would be just a formality,
但他没有接到面试电话。他的申请在提交工作申请时所做的性格测试这一关就被红牌罚下了。该测试是名为克罗诺斯（Kronos）的私人劳动力公司开发的员工甄选算法的一部分。这个国家70%的求职者在获得面试机会之前都要参加性格测试，所以由私人劳动力公司克罗诺斯开发的这个员工甄选算法。在这个国家，70%的求职者在获得面试机会之前都要参加性格测试。所以这是一种非常普遍的做法。
but he didn't get called back for an interview. His application was read-lited by the Personality Test he'd taken when he applied for the job. The test was part of an employee selection algorithm developed by a private workforce company called Kronos. 70% of job applicants in this country take Personality Test before they get an interview, so this employee selection algorithm developed by a private workforce company called Cronos. 70% of job applicants in this country take personality tests before they get an interview. So this is a very common practice.
凯尔通过他的朋友在克罗格工作，才得知自己通过了那次筛选，但他发现自己未能通过测试。所以大多数人永远不会发现这一点，他们只是收不到任何回复。关于凯尔的另一件不寻常的事是，他的父亲是一名律师。所以他的父亲就问：“这个测试上的问题是什么样的？”
Kyle had that screening and he found out because his friend worked at Crogers that he had failed the test. So most people never find that out, they just don't hear back. And the other thing that was unusual about Kyle is that his dad is a lawyer. So his dad was like, what were the questions like on this test?
他说：“嗯，其中有很多问题很像我在医院里受到的那些问题，也就是心理健康评估。”凯尔在医院接受的测试被称为五因素模型测试（five factor model test），它对人们的外向性、宜人性、尽责性、神经质和对新思想的开放性进行评分。它被用于心理健康评估。然后，潜在员工对测试的回答被输入到一个算法中，该算法决定是否应该录用此人。所以他的父亲就觉得：“哇，这在美国残疾人法案（ADA）下是违法的。”因此，他的父亲和他一起弄清楚了有些非常可疑的事情正在发生，
And he said, well, there are some of them were a lot like the questions I got at the hospital, the mental health assessment. The test Kyle got at the hospital was called the five factor model test, and it grades people on extroversion, agreeableness, conscientiousness, neuroticism, and openness to new ideas. It's used in mental health evaluations. The potential employees' answers to the test are then plugged into an algorithm that decides whether the person should be hired. So his father was like, whoa, that's illegal under the American Disability Act. So his father and he sort of figured out together that something very fishy had been going
他的父亲实际上为此对克罗格提起了一起集体诉讼。该诉讼目前仍在审理中，但辩论的焦点可能集中在性格测试是否可以被视为体检。如果是的话，根据《美国残疾人法案》，这将是非法的。奥尼尔明白不同的工作需要不同性格类型的人，但她说，招聘算法是一个生硬且不受监管的工具，最终会淘汰掉一大类人，这使它成为典型的数学毁灭武器。在某些工作中，你可能不希望有神经质的人或
on, and his father's actually filed a cross class action lawsuit against Kroger's for that. The suit is still pending, but arguments are likely to focus on whether the personality test can be considered a medical exam. If it is, it'd be illegal under the ADA. O'Neill gets that different jobs require people with different personality types, but she says a hiring algorithm is a blunt and unregulated tool that ends up disqualifying big categories of people, which makes it a classic weapon of math destruction. In certain jobs, you wouldn't want neurotic people or
内向的人。比如，如果你在一个有很多非常生气的客户打电话给你的呼叫中心工作。这可能会是个问题。在这种情况下，如果你为你的公司获得了特例，它实际上是合法的。问题在于，这些性格测试并不是针对每家企业精心设计的，相反发生的情况是，这些公司只是把同样的性格测试卖给所有愿意买它们的商业机构。奥尼尔在书中探讨的许多算法
introverted people. Like, if you're at a call center where a lot of really, I rate customers call you up. That might be a problem. In which case, it is actually legal if you get an exception for your company. The problem is that these personality tests are not carefully designed for each business, but rather what happens is that these companies just sell the same personality test to all the businesses that will buy them. A lot of the algorithms that O'Neill explores
在很大程度上是隐藏的。它们没有受到太多关注。作为消费者、求职者和雇员的我们，甚至可能没有意识到它们正在我们的生活中默默运转，将我们分门别类地归入各种堆栈和类别中。但最近有一类算法在新闻中受到了极大的关注。社交媒体能够渗透到政治中，这是一件好事还是坏事？社交媒体是一种技术，正如我们所知，技术有其好的一面，也有黑暗的一面，有那些不太好的一面。
in a book are largely hidden. They don't get a lot of attention. We as consumers and child applicants and employees may not even be aware that they're humming along in the background of our lives, sorting us into piles and categories. But there is one kind of algorithm that's gotten a lot of attention in the news lately. Is this a good or bad thing that social media has been able to infiltrate politics. Social media is a technology and as we know, technologies have their good size and the dark size, they're not so good size.
所以这一切都取决于……在我们的对话接近尾声时，奥尼尔和我开始讨论最近的选举，以及社交媒体算法塑造我们接收到的新闻的复杂方式。Facebook根据他们认为我们想要的东西向我们展示一则报道，当然，他们认为我们想要什么又是基于算法的。这些算法会查看我们之前点击过的内容，然后向我们推送更多我们喜欢的内容。其结果是，我们最终陷入了这些信息茧房中，日益极化，对持不同政治倾向的人可能会看到的内容浑然不觉。我确实认为这是一个重大
So it all depends on... Towards the end of our conversation, O'Neil and I started talking about the recent election and the complex ways that social media algorithms shaped the news that we receive. Facebook shows a story as based on what they think we want and of course what they think we want is based on algorithms. These algorithms look at what we clicked on before and then feed us more content we like. The result is that we've ended up in these information silos increasingly polarized and oblivious to what people of different political persuasions might be seen. I do think this is a major
问题。这简直可以说是无远弗届。我们构建了互联网，而互联网就是一个宣传机器。如果你愿意的话，它是一个宣传分发工具。而且这，我看不出这怎么能停下来。是的，尤其是如果每一个时刻都在被旨在操纵你情绪的算法所优化的话。
problem. The sort of the sky's the limit. We have built the internet and the internet is a propaganda machine. It's a propaganda delivery device, if you will. And that's not, I don't see how that's going to stop. Yeah, especially if every moment is being optimized by an algorithm that's meant to manipulate your emotions.
对，这完全回到了Facebook的优化算法。那不是在为真理进行优化，对吧？它是在为利润进行优化。它们声称自己是中立的，但当然，没有什么东西是中立的。我们已经看到了结果。我们已经看到了它实际上是为了什么而优化的，那并不美观。这种基于数据的政治微定位意味着阴谋论和虚假信息可以在网络上获得惊人的关注。宣称教皇方济各支持唐纳德·特朗普
Right, that's going exactly going back to Facebook's optimizer algorithm. That's not optimizing for truth, right? It's optimizing for profit. And they claim to be neutral, but of course, nothing's neutral. And we have seen the results. We've seen what it's actually optimized for, and it's not pretty. This kind of data-driven political micro-targeting means conspiracies and misinformation can gain surprising traction online. Stories claiming that Pope Francis endorsed Donald Trump
以及希拉里·克里特顿（此处指希拉里·克林顿）向“伊斯兰国”出售武器的报道在Facebook上获得了数百万的浏览量。这两篇报道都不是真的。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，Facebook，这两篇报道都不是真的。]解决这些破坏性算法带来的问题绝非易事，尤其是当它们正渗透到我们生活的越来越多的方面时。但奥尼尔认为，衡量标准和透明度是一个良好的开端，比如Facebook的算法及其向用户投放的政治广告。如果你要与Facebook谈论如何将一些道德规范注入他们的优化中，
and that Hillary Clinton's sold weapons to ISIS gained millions of viewers on Facebook. Neither of those stories was true. [♪ Music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, Facebook, neither of those stories was true. Fixing the problem of these destructive algorithms is not going to be easy, especially when they're insinuating themselves into more and more parts of our lives. But O'Neill thinks that measurement and transparency is one place to start, like with that Facebook algorithm and the political ads that it serves to its users. If you were to talk to Facebook about how to inject some ethics into their optimization,
你会怎么做？你会为真相的底线是一种更长远、赚更多钱的方式进行辩护吗？还是你会直截了当地说：这关乎道德，你们应该考虑道德？老实说，如果我真的能引起他们的注意，我会要求他们在网络上自愿找一个空间，把每一条政治广告，实际上是每一条广告，都放上去，让记者和对知情公民概念感兴趣的人能够查看他们在特定时间在Facebook上投放的所有广告。
what would you do? Would you sort of make a case for the bottom line of truth being a longer tail way to make more money? Or would you just say, this is about ethics and you should be thinking about ethics? To be honest, if I really had their attention, I would ask them to voluntarily find a space on the web to just put every political ad, and actually every ad, just have a way for journalists and people interested in the concept of the informed citizenry, to go through all the ads that they have on Facebook at a given time.
因为即使关于希拉里·克林顿和“伊斯兰国”的那篇文章被分享了数千次，许多人也根本没有看到过它。向我们展示你们正在向其他人展示的内容吧。因为我认为最具危害性的问题之一，其实是我们不知道其他人正在看到什么。我并不是在等待Facebook真正违背自身利益并改变其利润目标，但我确实认为这种透明度是可以被要求并被给予的。奥尼尔还表示，衡量这些算法的广泛影响并
Because even if that article about Hillary Clinton and ISIS was shared thousands of times, lots of people never saw it at all. Just show us what you're showing other people. Because I think one of the most pernicious issues is the fact that we don't know what other people are seeing. I'm not waiting for Facebook to actually go against their interests and change their profit goal, but I do think this kind of transparency can be demanded and given. O'Neill also says it's important to measure the broad effects of these algorithms and
理解它们对谁的影响最大至关重要。每个人都应该开始对其进行衡量。我的意思是，这相对简单。这可能不是一个完美的开始，但却是一个相当不错的起点，那就是：衡量这对谁失效。这意味着，哪些人群受这些算法结果的负面影响最大？降临在那些算法对其失效的人身上的伤害是什么？这些失效在整个人群中是如何分布的？
to understand who they most impact. Everyone should start measuring it. What I mean by that is relatively simple. This might not be a complete start, but it's a pretty good first step, which is measure for whom this fails. Meaning, which populations are most negatively impacted by the results of these algorithms? And what is the harm that befalls those people, for whom it fails? And how are the failures distributed across the population?
因此，如果你发现一个招聘算法对女性失效的频率远高于男性，这就是一个问题。尤其是当失效的结果是她们在应该被录用时却没有被录用时。我真的认为，对失效的分布及其带来的伤害进行研究和密切审查，确实会是一个好的开端。如果你对算法如何影响你的生活还不够愤怒，在这些广告之后，我还有一个重磅消息要告诉你。我们目前接听的呼叫量高于平常。请保持在线，稍后会有客服人员为您服务。
So if you see a hiring algorithm fail much more often for women than for men, that's a problem. Especially if the failure is they don't get hired when they should get hired. I really do think that a study, a close examination of the distribution of failures and the harms of those failures would really be a good start. If you're not mad enough about how algorithms influence your life, I've got a doozy for you after these messages. We are currently experiencing higher call volumes than normal. Please stay on the line and then agent will be with you shortly.
这里有一个我认为挺有意思的例子，因为它既烦人又保密，但你永远不会察觉到。所以如果你拨打客户服务热线，我并不是说这总是会发生，但有时它确实会发生：你的电话号码将被用来回溯查明你是谁，系统会评估你到底是高价值客户还是低价值客户，如果你是高价值客户，你将比低价值客户更快地与客服代表通话。你会面临更长时间的等待。这就是如今企业做出决策的方式。你是第90，9位来电者。
Here's one that I think is kind of fun because it's annoying and secret, but you would never know it. So if you call up a customer service line, I'm not saying this will always happen but it will sometimes happen that your phone number will be used to back track like who you are, you will be as like are you a high-value customer or low-value customer, and if you're a high-value customer you'll talk to a customer service representative much sooner than if you're a low-value customer. You'll be help put on hold longer. That's how businesses make decisions nowadays. You are caller number 90, nine.
您的来电对我们至关重要。请保持在线。本周的 99% Invisible 由德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）制作，技术和混音制作由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）完成。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是高级制作人。库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）创作了所有音乐。其余员工包括埃弗里·特鲁曼-夏里富斯（Avery Truffman-Charifuses）、泰伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）以及我罗曼·马尔斯。
Your call is important to us. Please stay on the line. 99% of visible was produced this week by Delaney Hall, tech and mixed production by Emmett Fitzgerald. Katie Mingle is the senior producer. Kurt Colstead is the digital director. Sean Rial composed all the music. The rest of the staff includes Avery Trouffman-Charifuses, Taren Mazza and me Roman Mars.
特别感谢瑞安·基斯勒（Ryan Keesler）和考特尼·里德尔（Courtney Riddle）。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的广播街（Radio Row）制作。99% Invisible 是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最棒、最具创新性节目的联盟。我们得到了奈特基金会（Knight Foundation）
Special thanks to Ryan Keesler and Courtney Riddle. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco if produced on Radio Row in Beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is part of radio topia from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by the night foundation
以及像你这样慷慨解囊的听众的支持。你可以在 Facebook 上找到 99% Invisible 并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上 @我 Roman Mars，或者 @节目账号 99PI org，也可以在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上找到我们。但我们在互联网上的温馨家园——上面有比我们在广播中或播客中能告诉你的更多设计故事，我想这是一个播客。
and coin carrying listeners, just like you. You can find 99% of visible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But our lovely home on the internet with more design stories than we can ever tell you here on the radio, or Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But our lovely home on the internet with more design stories than we can ever tell you here on the radio or podcast, I guess this is a podcast.
就是我们的网站 99PI.org。RADIO TOPIORX RADIO TOPIORX FROM PORX。来自 PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Is our website at 99PI.org. RADIO TOPIORX RADIO TOPIORX FROM PORX. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的网站是 99PI.org。来自 PRX 的 RADIO TOPIORX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。